Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here!
You may know Margot Robbie best as Leonardo
DiCaprio's on-screen wife in Wolf Of Wall
Street or the mallet-wielding Harley Quinn
in Suicide Squad, but before she hit the big
time, the talented Australian actress made
a crust working at the fast-food chain Subway.
Thanks to a regular role in the Aussie soap
opera Neighbours, however, Robbie, whose nickname
is maggot, was able to say so-long to serving
sandwiches, and hello to future cinematic
stardom.
Now, to mark Robbie's latest big-screen outing,
I've put together 7 crazy, cool facts you
need to know about the trapeze-swinging, tattoo-giving
actress!
Robbie is a mega sports fan and when she moved
from Australia to the US in 2011 to star in
the TV drama series Pan Am, she captained
a softball team she formed with her co-stars,
and loved giving them pep talks and painting
their faces before each game!
Once in the States, Robbie also became part
of an amateur ice-hockey team.
And her experience in the rink could well
come in handy on screen as one of the movie's
that Robbie has lined up to star in is a biopic
of former figure skater Tonya Harding.
Robbie will also produce the movie through
her own production company, called LuckyChap
Entertainment, which she set up with some
of her housemates including childhood friend
and assistant Sophia Kerr and Robbie's boyfriend,
assistant director Tom Ackerley, who she met
while filming the World War Two movie Suite
Française in 2013.
While she was filming The Legend of Tarzan
in the UK with Harry Potter director David
Yates and True Blood star Alexander Skarsgård,
Robbie turned 24 years old, and celebrated
her birthday in style by holding a 24-hour-long
party!
The carousing kicked off with champagne at
home at 9am, continued with games in London's
Hyde Park, and was followed by burgers and
bar-hopping, and even included under-the-sea
and Western-themed costumes, and it all came
to a close with more champagne back at home
24 hours later!
After a night partying with friends in London,
Robbie got a call to audition for Wolf Of
Wall Street in New York!
But when she turned up later that day wearing
jeans and flat boots to meet the movie's casting
director Ellen Lewis, Lewis sent her away
to buy a tight dress and super-high heels.
When it came to the audition itself, Leonardo
DiCaprio's ad libs almost threw Robbie off
course until she decided to take a risk and
responded to his improvised 'now get over
here and kiss me' line by smacking him right
in the face!
DiCaprio and director Martin Scorsese had
a good laugh about it, and that dramatic performance
sealed the role for her.
Actually, Robbie seems to be getting a bit
of a rep for beating up her co-stars!
In the war comedy-drama Whiskey Tango Foxtrot,
there's a scene where Robbie's character playfully
punches Tina Fey and says 'We're going out
tonight!'
According to Fey, Robbie was so strong from
all the physical training she was doing for
Suicide Squad that her on-camera punch left
a huge bruise on Fey's arm, which lasted for
several days.
And then there's the sex scene Robbie filmed
with Alexander Skarsgård for The Legend of
Tarzan, which, according to Skarsgård, who
plays Tarzan, was the only time he got injured
during the whole shoot!
Apparently, director David Yates wanted the
scene to have an animalistic quality so was
encouraging Robbie to beat Skarsgård up!
Going back to Wolf Of Wall Street, Martin
Scorsese gave Robbie the option of wearing
a robe or underwear for that scene where she
seduces Leonardo DiCaprio's character in her
apartment wearing nothing but stockings and
high heels.
But Robbie refused, saying that her character
Naomi would be completely naked as her body
was her only form of currency in that world.
Still, Robbie was in need of some Dutch courage
to film those sex scenes, so knocked back
several shots of tequila before hitting the
set.
Oh, and by the way, many of those clingy outfits
Robbie wore in her other scenes actually belonged
to the movie's Oscar-winning costume designer
Sandy Powell, who originally wore them in
the 1990s!
If she wasn't an actress, Robbie says she'd
like to be a trapeze artist, which isn't quite
as weird as it might sound at first because
she actually has experience in that particular
area since, as a kid growing up in Australia,
she attended circus school.
And when she was just eight years old, she
even got her trapeze certificate, and took
it up again recently practising in classes
at Santa Monica Pier.
During the shoot for Suicide Squad, Robbie
really got into her crazy Harley Quinn character,
setting up her own Tattoo Parlour on set and
inking the word Skwad on to her co-stars'
arms.
But Robbie's penchant for tattoos and fascination
with needles goes back further.
A few years ago when she started living in
a shared house in London, she decided to make
it a rule that everyone living there had to
get a tattoo.
Then when her housemate and now boyfriend
Tom Ackerley was getting his tattoo done at
the local tattoo parlour, Robbie persuaded
him to let her take over from the tattoo artist!
After The Legend of Tarzan finished filming,
a friend of Robbie's gave her a tattoo gun
as a present, which she used to tattoo a journalist
during an interview and her Suicide Squad
co-stars!
So guys, which are your favourite Margot Robbie
movies?
And what would you like to see in a Harley
Quinn spin-off film?
I'd love to hear your thoughts in the comments
below.
If you enjoyed this video, do please like,
share and subscribe, and also check out my
DC Movies playlist with which has videos on
Wonder Woman, Suicide Squad and more.
Check out the links below.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee ki-yay movie lovers!